[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record
we talk about whatever we want
nikki you have kittens i do what were
you gonna do i was gonna show you big
mood work
or actually it might be out now i don't
know instagram coming out
you never know um i do have kittens
where did you get them from cute from
kittenrescue.org
are you fostering yeah i'm fostering but
um they're not
able to be adopted out until they're at
least eight weeks old and they have all
their shots and they're spayed and
neutered and stuff aren't you scared
you're gonna fall in love we're just
gonna keep
already falling in love i saw that
picture where you had a
blanket full of kitties and i was like
where
is this taken even and then steve told
me that yeah you guys are foster
the most [ __ ] up thing about it is we
get them
when they can barely [ __ ] move and
they [ __ ] all over the floor and they
pee all over the floor
like somebody else gets them when
they're litter trained and
they're ready to go welcome to being a
girlfriend it's [ __ ] oh
that was good what does that mean what
does that mean
we spend our whole lives training our
boyfriends and then they go off and
marry someone else
after they're all my exes didn't train
me for [ __ ]
you're different that's why i married
you my
i had to [ __ ] not if anything my exes
you trained them
my ex trained me aren't you appreciative
of her
the [ __ ] where'd she train you in look
at what i can do
you fell short you fell short you had to
pick up so
much sleep you'd unfuck the old train
why do you think i started weightlifting
that load was heavy i had the caesar
milan of trainers
okay the seats are below your return
you're trying to compliment your
ex-girlfriend
that's what you're trying to do right
now mark yeah that's what's happening
he's trying to have a bad day
like vicky would say no what he's really
saying is it was so traumatic
that he had to go through that to
realize
what heaven is really like he would
never say something like that i like how
you're trying to
help me i'm trying to [ __ ] help him
he was trying to say look what a bad job
she did
look she did such a bad job well he did
say this caesar milan
oh that's what i was who is that i don't
know who that no season behind the dog
whisperer oh they're cat people
oh you guys are happy but dog whisperer
everyone
knew dog whisperer i'm a jackson guy
jackson galaxy
that's the cat one that's the cat one oh
really there's a cat whisperer
yeah does he go no no cause cats aren't
like dogs they're smarter
and they are they're a little too smart
where i don't like that
i want i want them to be dumb so that
they can go like oh my god you're here
oh my god you're here again they do that
when they like you
yes aren't german shepherds smarter
german shepherds are smarter than cats
right i don't know i mean they're smart
for dogs i don't know if they're smarter
than you
they're not using [ __ ] cats to sniff
bombs and [ __ ]
or maybe they're too smart for that
they're like i smell like the shark for
free
they know where the bomb is but they're
like whatever i'm over it i hope it goes
okay
it's like there's nothing here you're
safe and then they watch you blow up
they're like
i feel like cats cats would just give
hints like maybe over there maybe
cats look pretty funny on a harness
though it's hilarious
they look so weird especially when they
hate it yeah
remember that homeless guy dragging that
cat no i don't want to remember that
it was pretty funny though remember that
awful awful memory yeah
it was pretty funny the cow was just
dragged on the [ __ ] ground like this
like i don't want to be
a [ __ ] yeah that was sad how
about walking bunnies
you see people doing that never yeah
they were where do you live
near old mcdonald bunny people i have a
thing about bunny people they're [ __ ]
weird i hate people are weird
cat and dog people can come together on
the fact that bunny people are [ __ ]
weird
wait what's wrong with their bunnies
let's kind of just add to that too well
i know one word
they're weight they're really they're
really in the cosplay but they shouldn't
be
who are the buddies people yeah bunny
people are weird your sister's a bunny
person she's not in a cosplay
well there's a lot of crossover on the
venn diagram with cosplay and bunny
people but cosplay people's
faces have changed over the years now
they're really pleasant
well cosplay girls are perfectly fine so
what guys the cosplay
dudes are so weird so weird thank you
especially steampunk dudes those guys
are [ __ ] i knew a cosplay dude that
had a chinchilla
and he was obsessed with his chinchilla
those are soft they're really soft isn't
it legal to have here
yeah and they need to be played with
like every day like you have to play
with them they need like a lot of
attention
i would have taken chinchilla snake or
lizard but yeah
didn't your sister have chinchillas mine
no she had a gerbil
oh a gerbil what is
weird like a big rat like a big hamster
like dumb chinchillas
what's that and they're not a sausage
look like nah they're gorgeous oh they
look like a big coat
like no i don't even know what it looks
like in coat form yeah
and they they can't bathe in water they
have to take a dust bath and they just
roll around to this dust and then that's
how they get clean but what about octopi
oh no wonder they look make great coats
it's kind of like a squirrel
bunny and a rat made a baby it's
interesting what they look like before
they become coats what's that
shut the [ __ ] up what's that royalty
coat where it's like
white but then the black dots down the
middle it's a jacket oh that's really
cool
but what is it called what's the animal
called a dalmatian
no no it's like a it's white like all
the like the medieval guys have it's
like white
and then it's like black the king yeah
king
robe yeah right like it'll be all red
but then the trim is white yeah yeah
yeah
the black dots yeah fox tails on the
trim there
white maybe it's the extinct european
tiger
you guys you guys want to know what my
other favorite animal my new other
animal is what is it cool i'm gonna tell
you what is it yeah a king [ __ ]
cobra
why they're so
that's another one that i saw so they
they mate for [ __ ] hours they [ __ ]
for hours which is tight
they can swim they're porn stars really
fast maybe they can't find the hole
maybe i'm all thinking it's hot yeah
like is it here
is it here they could swim i don't like
swimming snakes man
but they're [ __ ] sick they could
climb yeah they're don't climb around
your neck
i know but they're [ __ ] messed up i
like to dance with indian people
they love indians yes they like to be in
baskets
yeah i googled i googled the royal thing
the birthing and they're saying it's a
or mean or mean which is an air mass bag
which is like a weasel it looks like oh
they got weed
people did anal play with weasels what
is it i thought it was a hamsters
yeah it was hamster what's this name
from pretty woman do that dave that's a
lie wretched gear
gear right and it's a gerbil oh yeah
gerbil
it was a gerbil it died up his butthole
yeah it's a lie
oh it's the same animal that's in this
thing this famous painting
the only reason i know it's famous
because animal crossing oh
that is so sad what about you didn't
have to admit that i did though i'm a
vulnerable person
i don't which one i don't think i don't
feel ashamed of my stupidity huh
which one's the fake one oh the one
that's a raccoon i know that
they sell fake art in animal crossing
and you have to know the difference
between the real art and the fake art
yeah yeah guinea pigs are cool they purr
yeah my nephew had one and only purred
for him how long did they live
that guy lived before like years that's
the other thing don't rabbits
don't die in like two years they do they
die pretty fast that's why they multiply
they have a woman in the wild this is a
guinea pig i guess
they're just nature's food and i think
if you scare them they go ah
and they can have a heart attack yeah
dude that happened one time they're
mentally
food our power went out in our house uh
my sister had a rabbit and
because dropped went dark yeah why
because it's like well it's not supposed
to be night yet
it was like a noise because everything
turned off and it was like
like and then like the the rabbit was
dead you just
died like that yeah rabbits are meant to
die fast though
birds too if they get startled because
they're prey
yeah they're food usually if the animal
has um the eyes on d
side their food just like those stupid
goldfish but
i don't do bunnies have eyes on this
side yeah you have it on the side
predators predators usually have
eyeballs on the front yeah you're right
because they're always constantly like
trying to run away they're like we gotta
see where we're not gonna die the
predators are like my eyes on you
can you imagine if your eyes are on the
side like that how do you even it's blur
everything's blurry no
recently i started i i saw some
animation movie where
the the agent turns into a pigeon and so
he has like pigeon eyeballs and then
he ends up seeing 360. oh so good thing
you saw this animated movie yes and i
learned from this animated movie
it's like you have a 360 cam child's
movie
that's our only that's your defense yeah
so then he was a better spy when he was
a pigeon because he could see
360. no wonder it's so hard to catch
those [ __ ] i could see that
because they could see it coming from
all waves man
yeah and they're cocky about it too like
a car is coming and they're like come on
[ __ ] move and that they're like i got
time
they i know and i have to step on the
brakes because i'm like [ __ ] you fly
you don't even need a walk
why why are you doing this well those
flies see like 20 out they do
i hate flies i hate flies i swear to god
they only see me dude and they're
[ __ ] in my face
yeah they're always in my face yeah why
the [ __ ] do flies and [ __ ] bad guys
mosquitoes are that's why they're always
trying to get what like food what
food you want to find you want to find
exactly i like that's their accent
that's the mosquito accent they're like
cholos
[Laughter]
why are you so good at that i know dude
used to be a flying
but before that speaking of stories from
vegas
this video is brought to you by feelsbad
for me i just get like since i do
extreme sports and things like that
like i just get super adrenaline super
excited
and even though like i stop playing at
like 1 p.m or i stop mountain biking at
1 pm
i can't go to sleep so then fields hook
me up and i just go
like this and i just start to feel the
chill within like 10 minutes
yeah that's dope because feels is a
premium cbd delivered directly to your
doorstep
it naturally helps reduce stress anxiety
as joel mentioned
pain and sleeplessness yep and it's easy
to take place a few drops of fields
under your tongue and feel the
difference within minutes
the thing to remember about cbd is that
finding your right dose is important and
everyone's dose is different so
experiment play lisa leave from some
room to have fun over the course of a
week or so and you may need to take more
or less to get the effect you're after
are you new to cbd fields offers a free
cbd hotline to help guide your personal
experience that's awesome fuels works
naturally
to help you feel better there's no high
hangover or
addiction join the fields community to
get it delivered to your door every
month you'll save money on every order
and you can pause or cancel
anytime feels has me feeling my best
every day and can help you too become a
member
today by going to feels.com off the
record
and you'll get 50 off that's feels
spelled f
e a l s dot com slash after record
become a member and get 50
automatically taken off your first order
with free shipping
phills.com off the record where'd you
get your hands stuck in a door something
embarrassing
stuck in the door joe i don't know what
i would take to get
joe to be yeah like i just found out
that
when he would before get embarrassed his
ears would get hot and i just learned
this last week and i'm like me
no no no bart i just learned that from
bart cause you guys are similar
but i haven't gotten there i get
embarrassed you have to
last time i got embarrassed um
i get embarrassed but when yeah i know
when but i can't stay cause he'll get
embarrassed
that's true i know i know when because i
can't say because they're not gonna
marry us
actually oh i think i know it too
yeah you know it yeah anyway
so so since you want to talk about that
what would you like to talk about joe
wait a minute i don't even know what
we're doing what am i being embarrassed
about now i want to know i think she was
making it up and then i jumped in on it
it's what i'm assuming i thought you
knew something i didn't know
no because nothing embarrasses you
genuinely are you serious though you
think that nothing embarra
like there's times when i'm dude we see
how you dress how you talk
what you do you don't give a [ __ ] oh
those are the things that normal people
are embarrassed about yeah but i
i i do get embarrassed oh open up i want
to hear what's the last time you got
embarrassed
if people around me are being rude and
i'm like oh that's embarrassing
oh is yeah but like it depends on what
kind of route though like
like if i don't know like if there was a
karen around me and i'm like oh my god
you're my friend
you know what i mean like but when are
you embarrassed of yourself yeah that's
some people usually
myself yeah uh oh that's what people
that's what people
i know i know it i i think i know
that one we know it we got one i don't
feel embarrassed
um with myself is it myself yes yeah
it's myself yeah that's what people mean
when they say that yeah usually when i'm
embarrassed it's usually by myself
it's about me people don't go like oh
i'm so sorry for their friend
am i embarrassed now i'm really curious
maybe you know me better than i do no
you're not embarrassed because then this
is how long it's taking you to find a
[ __ ] instance where you were
embarrassed
that's what i'm saying i don't think joe
really gets embarrassed no i think the
whole room is saying that
oh i cringe for others that's my idea of
embarrassment yeah
i get that um well then conclusion he
doesn't get embarrassed
that's one of my favorite pastimes is
cringing at others
yeah especially in a public show bart
genuinely doesn't get embarrassed though
i do get embarrassed but it's very
difficult it's it's rare like what
embarrasses you
right now i can't do the same thing that
bart does
where he takes out the trash in his
underwear if i walk out i'll be like
don't look at me you can't do this oh
yeah that's good but then if i was in
the forest
and i was in my boxers with my friends
that's different because i already did
that
yeah because it's appropriate we're
jumping in the lake yeah
it's appropriate in certain situations
but not in the bart situation yeah
because bart will walk outside
take out the trash in his underwear and
he doesn't get embarrassed so i do get
embarrassed i will say the like
one of the first times i was a guest on
this show and bart came out in his
underwear i was like
am i supposed to like be in the room
right now
like should i leave yeah
i had those feelings i remember i'm he
just came out of like
the nap room or like he took a nap and
he came out of the room and it was in
his underwear
we have a whole wardrobe section so this
place is technically like a green room
too like a player
i barely knew you the jkhr rep killed
themselves by the way
but now i get it but at the at the time
i was like
i should have prepped am i supposed to
look you're like trying to make extra
eye contact with him
just to not make [ __ ] awkward mm-hmm is
that sexual harassment if i change in
front of someone
yeah if you show your wiener yes oh what
if i don't have my wheels you show your
butt
yes i think just getting in your
underwear i think that's
that could be it what if he's just
changing his shirt that's fine
because these nipples are okay yeah
that's right but what if i change my
shirt and i lick my own nipple and put
another shirt on
that's that's okay okay what if he licks
his own nipple while looking at you
and he's like oh that's a little
threatening okay that's multi-tasking
too
that's why you know it's illegal for men
in the 30s to have
to be shirtless that's why all their
bikini should have stayed that way
they had the jumpsuit thingy they had
the like little
muscle man yeah the one pieces and then
they parted their hair in the middle
that's cute yeah they have bulk they had
those changing rooms at the beach
those are cool how come we don't have
those now no no because people shatter
them
do you think 1920s uh ladies got horny
when they saw a shirtless dude oh yeah
yeah yeah they're just like
oh yeah it was crazy when you watch all
those old films like where everyone's
very elegant and stuff
no one shaved their pubes like everyone
just had big old bushes under all those
fancy clothes i heard that's coming back
it is but do you think they did oral
back then
yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah but how do
they know about it
it just feels good so then you get
creative where else can i stick together
but if it's
hairy and stinky down there because they
didn't shower as much but everybody's
gonna think you don't think of sucking
that dick dude yours is stinky too
no i take a shower no not you joe now
you have them you're talking about that
time they took a shower back then
everyone was equally ranked people
figured it out too dude
their smell threshold was just i'm
pretty sure they had showers back then
i wonder how they [ __ ] i'm really
curious how they [ __ ]
because like when you see ancient art
like there'll be like a greek
vase that's like a thousand years old
and then they'll be like
um a girl getting doggy styled and then
like a guy doggy styling the guy that's
doggy stuff
i love those vases you know like they
had fun back then i'm like
that's interesting and then the artist
is carving the vase
yeah can you stay still please stay
still please
he's like i can't stay hard like this
right it's like a greek party and it's
like
this girl got two dicks going down this
way and i'm like wow
like they just explored back then you
know i was watching this document
documentary where um they i guess like
they made a plant extinct in greece that
used to be
uh very popular but it was a birth
control oh
they used it too so much that it went
extinct oh yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] get that plan to stick
it up their [ __ ]
no i think they ate it oh damn i found
out
birth control in egypt the way that they
did it
is they used some animal [ __ ] and mixed
it with some kind of poison
and stuck it up their [ __ ] that was a
spermicide
can you imagine sticking animal [ __ ]
inside your
they're vagina so many people must have
died from kidney
infections because like the utis weren't
right treatable
isn't that crazy people been wanting to
[ __ ] and not have kids
yeah for a long time or get diseases
they'd rather die from a uti
than have a kid that's some crazy [ __ ]
right
i met some kids who yeah i think i'd
rather have a uti thank you
you